- The Gilbert U-238 Atomic Energy Lab.
The Atomic Energy Lab was
designed to help children
learn how to make nuclear
weapons, seriously.
Sometimes kids' toys can
have adult consequences.
When you were a kid, did
you ever wish for a toy
that seemed a little too dangerous?
- No, no, I want an official
Red Ryder carbine-action
200 shot range model air rifle.
- You'll shoot your eye out kid.
- From lawn darts to easy bake ovens
it seems that toy makers
secretly want to kill you.
They've invented toy
weapons, deadly dolls,
and lab kits containing
asbestos and even uranium.
So let's put on our lawyer hat
and look at some of
the most dangerous toys
that have ever been invented
and discuss how legal
or illegal they were.
Now, there was a time when 'CSI'
was the most popular TV show in the world.
The show aired at 10:00 PM
and obviously was geared towards
and mostly popular with adults.
But the thing is, why monetize just adults
when you can also monetize children?
(rockstar screams)
So the executives at CBSs capitalized
on the popularity of 'CSI'
by giving Planet Toys a license
to make 'CSI' themed toys.
The company passed on the obvious choices,
sunglasses for David Caruso wannabes.
(rockstar screams)
And instead came up with
two fingerprint kits
for kids who shouldn't be
watching the show anyway.
But this quickly turned
into a fiasco when tests
conducted by the Asbestos
Disease Awareness Organization
revealed that the kits
contained white powder
that consisted of 7% tremolite,
one of the most dangerous
forms of asbestos.
Asbestos is a potent
carcinogen in any form
but it poses the greatest health risk
when it is in tiny particulates
which are allowed to become airborne
and easily enter the body.
This is precisely the form that it took
in the 'CSI' forensics kit.
When confronted with the test results,
Planet Toys told retailers
to stop sales of the 'CSI' exam kit.
However, the company refused
to stop selling the 'CSI' lab kit
which contained the
same fingerprint powder
and it refused to voluntarily
recall either of the products.
As you might have guessed,
this didn't end well
for Planet Toys, which filed
for Chapter seven bankruptcy
in 2009, declaring liabilities
of at least 10 million.
Chapter seven bankruptcy
is the kind of bankruptcy
where there's no reorganization
or managing of debts.
The company just gives up.
A good idea to quit while you're ahead
instead of losing a bunch of money
in seeing the mesothelioma
consequences of your actions
40 years down the line.
And not surprisingly, CBS later settled
a class action lawsuit
brought by the people who
had purchased those kits.
Now that takes us to the Swing Wing.
♪ A brand new Transogram fun thing ♪
- [Announcer] It's a what?
♪ It's a Swing Wing ♪
- The Swing Wing was invented
by an out of work chiropractor.
No, that's not a joke.
Now, how do you think your neck would feel
after five minutes of this motion?
Look at this kid go.
This toy consists of a ribbon
with weighted balls attached to it,
which fits around a child's head,
kind like a cranial weed wacker.
Now, I can't imagine what could go wrong
with a rope that's being
swung around a child's neck.
Look, elephants and monkeys
enjoy watching kids use it
which isn't an unorthodox
way to market a toy.
Also, maybe those elephants
and monkeys are just hungry
and waiting for kids to commit
their own sort of Darwin Award.
Not surprisingly, the
Swing Wing was pulled
from shelves because many
kids who played with the toy
suffered cerebral hemorrhages
and neck injuries.
Who would've predicted
that whipping your head
back and forth with weighted balls
would be bad for you?
Now the bestselling toy for boys in 1964
was the Johnny Seven One Man Army.
(rapid gunfire)
- [Announcer] Your squad is ready
for you to lead them through
with Johnny Seven, the One Man Army Gun.
- Released during the Cold War,
this toy had everything kids needed
to survive their own Red Dawn
including a grenade
launcher, an anti-armor gun,
an anti-tank rocket,
an anti bunker missile,
a Tommy gun, and a semi-automatic
pistol that fired caps
with a rifle with 12 bullets.
When fully deployed, this
toy was three feet long
and weighed four pounds.
Four pounds of pure
military grade testosterone.
Detective Goren demonstrated
all seven weapons
on an episode of Law and
Order criminal intent.
- Seven weapons in one,
grenade launcher,
(gun pops)
anti-tank rocket,
armor piercing shell,
(gun pops)
anti bunker missile,
machine gun,
(gun clicks)
repeater rifle, cap gun.
- I definitely want one.
Also, I support military
interventionism now. That's weird.
But this toy is legendary.
Captain Kangaroo banned ads
for the Johnny Seven One Man Army
from his show because he didn't
want to promote violence.
That of course just made it even cooler
and it's become a kind of
holy grail for toy collectors.
It can even be yours for
the low, low price of $450
on eBay with $60 for shipping.
Freedom ain't free baby.
So is it illegal to sell a toy like this?
Well, generally not.
1970s consumer advocates
petition the US Consumer
Product Safety Commission
to regulate or ban toy guns.
The federal government
considered it for years
but eventually agreed to allow toy makers
to create their own list
of voluntary standards.
These standards focus on warning labels
and clear instructions, but
leave the design of the toys
largely up to the manufacturer.
Today there's just one federal
law regulating toy guns,
15 U.S.C. section 5001
which requires toy guns to
have a blaze orange plug
on the muzzle to distinguish
toy guns from the real thing.
This law was passed in 1986
and it applies retroactively
to all toys manufactured,
designed, and produced since 1898.
However, the law does
not stop the end user
from modifying the weapon.
So today, the Johnny Seven
One Man Army would be illegal
unless they painted the muzzle orange.
But don't come crying to me
if the police shoot your
children as a result.
I'm just kidding.
The police will shoot
your children anyway.
And now that takes us
from guns to vegetables.
Developed in 1978 by Xavier Roberts,
Cabbage Patch Kids dolls were
all the rage in the 1980s
and came in many variations.
Hasbro bought the rights to the brand
and started producing a
line of Cabbage Patch Kids
with various functions.
Enter 1995 Snack Time Kids,
a munching and chewing doll,
which sounds like a nightmare.
And for hundreds or thousands of kids
it probably did inspire a few nightmares.
As you can see, the
dolls had moving mouths
and let kids feed these fat
dolls with plastic snacks.
After the kids fed the doll,
the food was deposited into a backpack.
Obviously this has all the
hallmarks of a bad idea.
What kid would stop with the
plastic french fries and gum?
And why not try feeding
the doll's real food?
If parents weren't paying
attention and any food got stuck
the food just stayed
there until it rotted.
But that wasn't the biggest
problem with these dolls.
The biggest problem was
that these Snack Time Cabbage Patch kids
had a taste for human
flesh or at least hair.
(terrified scream)
(booming thunder)
And the bigger problem was
that the doll didn't have
an on or an off switch.
The mouth operated by
having rollers move the food
and if the food kept on coming,
the rollers kept on moving.
This meant that kids got their hair caught
in a doll's mouth, which
was designed to keep rolling
up until whatever it bit
ended up in the backpack.
For some kids, that meant being
trapped for up to 30 minutes
while their parents dismantled the doll
by chopping it's head off
and then searching the body
cavity for the batteries.
Hundreds of irate parents complained
and Mattel voluntarily recalled the toys
and paid $40 refunds to 500,000 people
who purchased this cannibal
Cabbage Patch Doll.
That takes us to Sky Dancers.
Sky Dancers look innocent enough.
These are dolls that can fly.
- They're flying!
♪ Fly for me, just for me,
Sky Dancer dance for me ♪
- Wow! They really fly!
- Just pull the string and watch
them soar like helicopters.
Children loved them and
they were popular enough
to stay on the market from 1994
until the turn of the century
when the US government
declared them too dangerous.
The US Consumer Product
Safety Commission is charged
with protecting the public
from unreasonable risks
of injury or death associated
with the use of thousands
of types of consumer products.
And according to the CPSC,
Sky Dancers had a propensity to fly
and go in unpredictable directions
and causing all kinds of harm.
And in fact, when I was a kid,
I busted open my lip
with a similar product.
Why? Because when you pull the string
you naturally put your
face directly in front
of the spinning death helicopters
and the hard plastic that was used
for the wings could do some real damage.
And the toy company received 170 reports
that the dolls were striking children
and adults resulting in
150 reports of injuries.
Injuries reported included eye injuries
including scratch corneas
and incidents of temporary blindness,
broken teeth, mild
concussion, a broken rib,
and facial lacerations
that required stitches.
But all's well that ends well
when the CPSC ordered a recall
of 8.9 million Sky Dancers.
Now, one of the best
ways to aggravate parents
is to sell a toy that is
both noisy and dangerous.
And that's just what toy
makers achieved with Klackers
a kid version of bolas
a weapon that Argentinian
gauchos used to hunt.
- [Announcer] The new
original miracle Klackers
won't shatter even if you use both hands.
Try stereo klacking with
unbreakable miracle Klackers
- Bolas are a throwing weapon
made of weights on the end
of interconnected cords.
In fact, the only real difference
between Klackers and the deadly bolas
is that Klackers are shorter
and not made of wood.
Just like attorney Tom.
Someday you'll be a real boy.
Now rather than throwing them at animals
to tangle up their legs,
kids were supposed to swing the Klackers
until they made an ear splitting noise.
(rockstar screaming)
What could possibly go wrong?
Well, they violate Legal
Eagle's rule number one
for kids' toys,
anything that can be used as a weapon
will be used as a weapon.
Now, the first Klackers
appeared in the late 60s
and they were made from tempered glass
which contrary to the marketing
about being unbreakable
would eventually shatter,
pelting users with shards of glass.
Eventually, the US government
classified Klackers
as a mechanical hazard in the court case
and worst epic rap battle of history,
United States versus article consisting
of 50,000 cardboard boxes, more or less,
each containing one pair of Klacker balls.
Now this case became famous
because people were amused by the fact
that the government seemed to
have sued the Klacker balls
and the boxes that they were
contained in themselves.
But that's because the seizure
was an exercise of jurisdiction in-rem.
Jurisdiction in-rem is a legal term
describing the power a court
may exercise over property.
It assumes that the property or status
is the primary object of the action.
Classic cases involving
jurisdiction in-rem
include United States versus
one Tyrannosaurus Bataar skeleton,
South Dakota versus 15 impounded cats,
and one 1958 Plymouth
Sedan versus Pennsylvania.
In the case of the Klackers,
the United States Marshals
seized a shipment of Klacker balls
and the Ace Novelty
Company filed a complaint
against forfeiture
arguing that the shipment
was not a banned hazard
as defined by the Federal
Hazardous Substances Act.
The government argued that
the Klackers were hazardous
as the term was defined in 16 CFR 1500.18
which bans toys presenting
a mechanical hazard.
And while the Ace Novelty Company argued
that there was an exception,
the court sided with the US government
and eventually banned the bolas.
I mean children's toy.
- [Announcer] Look for this package.
- Now, just about everyone is familiar
with the Slip N' Slide
a staple of the summer.
- [Announcer] Okay,
everybody come outside.
Everybody ready for a wild wet ride?
♪ Slip, Slip N' Slide. ♪
The Slip N' Slide was
invented by Robert Carrier
after watching his son deliberately slide
across wet concrete and
carpet in the garage.
Carrier was an upholster who worked
with a company that produced boat seats.
So he borrowed a 50
foot roll of Naugahyde,
installed a hose,
and invented one of the
most iconic summer toys.
Carrier took his invention
to the Wham-O company,
which was behind the popular
toys like the Frisbee
and the Hula Hoop.
Naugahyde was replaced with plastic
and the toy went on sale in 1961.
Now obviously everyone loved it
and initially there were
few injuries reported
but the Slip N' Slide soon
encountered a problem.
Kids loved it so much that
adults wanted to join in.
Adults who maybe had a few too
many cans of lawsuit juice.
(elevator music)
Lawsuit juice. It's not beer, we swear.
Okay, it's totally just beer.
But the Slip N' Slide was
not designed for adults.
The instruction said that
the product was designed
for children 10 and over
and presumably that didn't
include youthful grownups.
In 1987 a 34 year old man broke
his neck and was paralyzed
after using a Slip N' Slide.
A jury decided that the
Slip N' Slide was defective
and unreasonably dangerous
and gave the plaintiff over $12 million.
In 1988, a University of
Central Florida student
also broke his neck on the slide.
He won his lawsuit as well
and the toy company took the
Slip N' Slide off the market.
Eventually, in 1993,
the US Consumer Product Safety Commission
issued a recall notice
and the Slip N' Slide was Slip N' Shelved.
Fortunately for kids, the Slip N' Slide
has been given a new life.
You can buy a new one
complete with a warning
that it's only safe for kids 12 and over.
So to all of you kids and adults out there
please Slip N' Slide responsibly.
Or don't, I'm not your parent,
though I can represent you
in a lawsuit over a horrific injury.
(better Call Saul theme music)
Now, if these toys aren't
scary enough for you
then you might be interested
in the Gilbert U-238 Atomic Energy Lab.
This set was created by
Alfred Carlton Gilbert
who was also the inventor
of the Erector Set.
His Atomic Energy Lab was
designed to help children
learn how to make nuclear weapons.
No, seriously. This toy actually
included uranium samples.
It came with four glass jars
containing natural uranium
barium ore samples.
The goal was for kids
to learn how to create
and watch nuclear and chemical reactions
using radioactive materials.
Obviously. How else are you gonna do it?
Gilbert insisted this was a safe toy
as long as you didn't break the seals
on the uranium samples.
You know, how kids don't break
the toys that they're given.
Luckily, the lab included
a real Geiger counter,
an electroscope, a Wilson cloud chamber,
and some low level radiation sources,
including zinc, polonium,
and ruthenium isotopes
labeled alpha, beta,
and gamma, depending on
which particular radiation
particles they emitted.
Now, the product catalog explains
that the atomic reactions
are beautiful to watch.
They're particularly beautiful
once you've had the kit long
enough to grow a third eyeball.
And despite the hype,
this toy never caught on
and fewer than 5,000 kits were ever sold.
It cost $47 in the 1950s
which was the equivalent
of at least $550 today.
Now, the Atomic Energy Lab
was meant to make kids smarter
but it would've only resulted
in kids getting a third arm.
But one non-radioactive
way for kids and adults
to actually learn about
mathematics and science
is through today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online learning platform
for STEM that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious learners
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
You can quickly learn to
ace your high school exams,
college math courses,
or just learn stuff that
you always wanted to learn.
For example, if the makers of these toys
had taken Brilliant's logic
course maybe they would've known
that it was a crazy idea
to create all of these
insanely dangerous toys,
Because Brilliant's Logic courses cover
liar and truth teller
riddles, logical fallacies,
machine logic, and even
strategic game theory.
And logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day,
especially when they're
suing toy manufacturers.
And I also really enjoyed Brilliant's
Data Science Foundations course
which starts with probability fundamentals
and builds up to using data predictions,
experimentation, and neural networks.
It's the kind of thing where
you learn to understand
an introduction of probability,
applied statistics,
and statistics fundamentals.
Because Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures,
learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
Now you can sign up and
start learning for free today
by going to brilliant.org/LegalEagle
or clicking on the link
that's on screen right now.
And the first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
So by clicking on the link below
you'll get 20% off your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus clicking that link
really helps out this channel.
And after that, click
on this box over here
for more Legal Eagle or
I'll see you in court.